hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead midseason finale
video someday this pain will be useful
to you so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet cuz they
actually did some big comic book stuff
if there's anything I feel like people
are gonna walk away being upset by
though is this all the comic book stuff
that they did not do because we are in
the middle of no way out just in terms
of comic book storylines and it did not
end the way that no way out ended hold
that hope if you want though they could
totally push the ending of no way out
like some of the things some of the
deaths that end up happening into the
second half of the season but just a
quick reminder there is a new round of
the giveaway that starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just a
$20 Amazon gift card just because there
were so many clear WTF things in this
episode I'm gonna do top 10 this time
starting with Sam cannot close his mouth
as they proceed through the tulips or
the walkers have you want to think about
it
I totally love that that song was
playing in the background so creepy the
opening scene was Sam right there that's
exactly why you don't let children take
food to their room
even though Ron seems like he's the weak
point in the group right now I think
that Sam is the weakest link he is
probably going to track markers to them
seriously just trying to get his mom's
attention on a number 9 though bran goes
after Carl with the gun my mom my
brother my dad they're all dead you're
dead too when people were talking about
this going down before the episode they
were really like two things happening
you know like one what was Ron gonna do
like was he gonna go after Carl or
wasn't he into what was going to happen
during their encounter if you want to
talk about Carl from the comics be sure
to use spoiler tags because the whole
encounter is very different from what
happens in the comics the only thing I
was pretty sure about was like the
second part like what would not be
happening to Carl as a result of this
encounter I think that's the only way I
can say it without actually doing
spoilers for the comic the show is
completely sidestepped a big thing with
Rick's character like a big twist with
his character so I kind of expected the
same treatment with Carl's character but
yeah I definitely think that Carl is
giving Ron way too much credit like he
lies to Jessie and Rick about what
happened in the garage
we were trying to get tools WTF dude the
kids gonna keep coming after you you
might as well sell him out now I know I
said Sam is the weakest link in the
group right now but just look at Ron
he's already kind of in Walker mode
anyway he looks like he is absolutely
ready to commit Walker assisted suicide
at any moment
on the number 8 Maggie gets stuck on top
of the platform and they did not resolve
it they'll ever have top there Glenn
sees her with Enid and we have to wait
till the second half of the season to
find out what happens to her she's
pregnant read between the lines she's
definitely not gonna die she's totally
safe they're not gonna kill her with a
baby in her stomach if they were gonna
do that they would wait till she was
super pregnant that's actually a good
pole to take do you think that the
Walking Dead would ever have the
quote-unquote guts to kill a pregnant
woman especially a main character who
was pregnant even though the show airs
on cable and it's a super bloody comic I
just I feel like that's something that
they would never do I know they killed
Laurie but they didn't kill her till
after she had baby Judith and for those
of you asking about baby Judith she got
put underneath one of those walker tarps
that they were wearing so Rick's holding
her underneath the guts so they didn't
actually have to put guts on the baby's
face could you imagine them on set we're
gonna have to put some walker guts on
your baby's face ma'am I can't even
begin to imagine a stage mom that would
let them do that to their baby I don't
my number 7 WTF Deanna gets bitten and
is definitely going to die the wound is
so grievous there's no question about it
she's definitely gonna die by the end of
the episode but Michonne knows about her
plan that she was riding on that map and
they're gonna try and execute it it's
just a way to deal with the super hoard
but Deanna gets that moment with each of
the characters like Bob got last season
where she imparts wisdom as she goes out
like she tells Rick you were the best
man for the job I didn't save you
because your good father or because you
can grow the best damn beard ever I save
you because you're the right man for the
job we're at the tail end of Movember so
who misses Rick's beard by the way it
was getting pretty crazy by the time
they found the same stone last year
Pantani my number six WTF Denise gets
trapped with the crazy wolf Morgan is
keeping prisoner you know who he reminds
me of when he's giving her that crazy
philosophy speech it's the Joker like
the Joker is a very learned person he's
very smart very intelligent but he just
has the craziest ideas so he will twist
your mind which is exactly what the
wolves are like they're a bunch of
twisted human beings really the tension
is is that she's going to help him like
show me your wound and that he's gonna
go after her when she does but the real
WTF doesn't come till later till Carol
barrels downstairs side bark - Rick
explaining his plan to everyone in the
house though we're gonna cover ourselves
in these guts don't worry I've done this
before
he actually he actually did do that in
previous season just like covered
himself with
Walker bits and we've seen Michonne do
it we've seen a bunch of characters do
this technically it's called Walker camo
there's also a group in the comics
called the whispers that wear face masks
they wear dead people's skin so that
also works too it's so much fun just
watching the characters react like Jesse
Gabriel apparently not big cosplayers
don't you want to cosplay as The Walking
Dead apparently they've never done The
Walking Dead experience at comic-con
before I was a little disappointed that
he didn't throw up but then Sam walks in
and it looks like he's already pooped
his pants when Jesse tells him what
they're gonna do just pretend you're
brave just fake it til you make it on a
my number three WTF Deanna goes down
fighting so she's gonna commit suicide
do the noble thing like give me the gun
I'll do it myself but then she hears the
walkers coming and just starts screaming
I love the way they cut the sound too
that's a very common technique well
someone will scream silently it just
like it forces you mentally to put your
scream in their mouth she goes down guns
blazing it's a great way to go out if
you're gonna go out on the Walking Dead
you might as well go out on your own
terms
Thunder my number two WTF Carroll versus
Morgan versus the wolf I think it went
down in a fairly predictable way didn't
we all expect that to end up happening
like the wolf was gonna somehow get the
upper hand and try to escape but I will
say hands down my favorite performance
in this episode was Carol Pelletier
seriously she is so compelling I'm gonna
kill him to keep him from killing anyone
else you know Morgan has a good
philosophy too I totally get it
but come on dude seriously this guy is
gonna kill everyone every chance he gets
let's just put him down let me know in
the comments like did any of you guys
agree with what Morgan was saying like
did you buy his whole sanctity of life
thing or would you have rather let Carol
just put him down but just to be clear
no one in that basement died Carol
Morgan even Denise and the wolf will be
back during the second half of the
season cuz they'll have to get Denise
back seriously she's like the only medic
they have they're gonna have to get her
back I thought what that is is that
they'll just give Denise this big moment
well she'll have to overcome the wolf by
herself like this big courageous hero
moment for her she's kind of like Eugene
where she doesn't have a lot of
self-esteem she doesn't believe in
herself a lot so this might be the
writers creating a challenge for her to
overcome and of course on my very
obvious number one WTF moment
post-credits scene
negan is introduced on the show verbally
at least your porn underneath the seats
give it to us that was my favorite funny
line like the minute I saw though
bikers in the street I knew it was gonna
be negan but the speech that they gave
was really funny everything you have the
gas in your car the truck itself if you
have porn underneath your seats belongs
to negan now couple big takeaways one
everyone can stop arguing about how to
pronounce his name Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is playing the character if you didn't
know he's Sam and Dean's dad from
Supernatural he's done a bunch other
stuff if you never watched Supernatural
you probably know him as the comedian
during the Watchmen movie in number two
they have skipped a whole bunch of comic
book arcs so right now where we're at is
around issue 84 in the comic like the
tail end of no way out
negan doesn't show up till issue 100
which is smack dab in the middle of
volume 17 so that's like way way later
it's well after hilltop and I think that
the show is doing that so while probably
seeing a bunch of people and characters
from volume 15 through volume 17 the
back half of the season so if you do
want to read along in the comic books
just start with volume 15 I guess we
also have to say bonus WTF fate they
made us wait til the first commercial
break Turing into the Badlands to see
this post-credit scene I saw a lot of
people really upset about that on
Twitter but let me know in the comments
below what did you guys think about this
episode and were you mad that they
didn't kill as many people as got killed
during this comic book storyline all
things being equal it's not over till
it's over but there are a bunch of
people that survived that did not
survive in the comics what's gonna
happen next is I will do a predictions
video for the second half of the season
because we do know they're doing more
comic-book stuff we know negan's coming
so we'll probably know where we're
headed next congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner dead turkey you
had a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so and get your contact info
now there is a bunch of Batman vs
Superman
Gotham flash arrow crossover stuff
happening next week so if you're not
sure what's going on just stay tuned you
can follow me on Twitter and Facebook
for updates on all that stuff there are
links at the bottom of the description
for that just in case you guys haven't
seen it you can click here for all my
Walking Dead Season 6 videos and you can
click here to learn all about the Batman
V Superman trailer that's coming
tomorrow night thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five
someday this pain will be useful to us